the britney spears conservatorship saga
may be coming to an end i just want to
be a happy person in court documents
obtained by e.t the pop star has
formally requested a termination plan to
end her conservatorship here's what we
now know in the docs filed on wednesday
britney's attorney matthew rosengart
asks that the singer's father jamie
spears be removed as conservator of her
estate and you guys know my situation
the attorney goes on to argue that 13
years after it was first installed
britney's conservatorship no longer
serves a legitimate purpose rosengart
also requests that jaime be temporarily
replaced until the conservatorship is
completely and inevitably terminated
this fall we pledged
that after 13 years of the status quo
my firm and i would move aggressively
and expeditiously
to file a petition to suspend
and remove james p spears it's all
referred to as the termination plan in
these docks which state that britney
wants this process to begin immediately
i'm very keen on freedom i love freedom
i love independence the new development
follows a recent court filing from jaime
who also requested an end to the
conservatorship he's saying
the judge has decided already
that
she can make decisions like picking her
own lawyer and
brittany says
that she's prepared to move on with her
life in a petition submitted two weeks
ago jamie stated that his daughter is
entitled to have this court now
seriously consider whether this
conservatorship is no longer required
and he's sort of pushing it on to
everyone else saying look
the judge decided this
brittany feels this way her lawyer says
this and as a result it seems to me that
we could end the conservatorship so
it's not like he's coming forward and
saying it is time
um i am convinced that
this is ready for this to end it's more
sort of everyone else seems to believe
this so i'm not going to stand in their
way
britney had a fear that her family would
barge in and take everything what was
going on inside the conservatorship and
why was she still in one and she was
quote okay also on wednesday we got our
first look at the latest documentary to
examine brittany's case there was
financial incentives for jamie for the
lawyers i've represented dozens of
conservatives in court not one of them
has ever had a job brittany made other
people a lot of money in the trailer for
britney vs spears the netflix movie
teases new interviews from brittany's
so-called inner circle and never before
seen documents from the pop icons legal
battle someone very close to the
conservatorship leaked me this
confidential report brittany had to go
into court a million times all of these
hours of criticizing her it's an epic
fail of the legal system that this has
gone on for so long brittany versus
spears begins streaming september 28th
on netflix no one would talk
i'm not going to acknowledge that i was
ever brought in to evaluate britney
spears
until they did
you